on friday night we had dinner with a
couple guys that are you know hollywood
type of guys you know actors producers
directors and we're having dinner with
them and i said so you guys politically
you you don't lean towards the right you
lean towards the left this is what side
you've been on yeah what about it
how do you feel about what's going on in
your city and your state what do you
think about masks next week what do you
think about your governor
and and you'd be amazed what they said
they said pat low key
there aren't many people in hollywood
that support this guy but what's the
alternative if you're going to be vocal
about it you have to if you're in the
entertainment industry you have to even
in the entertainment business you either
support just to get career advancement
or you just don't talk about it okay
they're not happy about the math can you
pull up that nbc story i just sent you
look at this la county indoor mask man
they could come back this week look at
the date yesterday july 25th there you
go la county indoor mask management come
back this week